عوامل وعده تؤثر على مستويات اليقظه لدى
الافراد بحسب الباحثين اولها مده النوم
وتوقيته فعندما ينام الشخص لفتره اطول من
المعتاد او يستيقظ في وقت متاخر عن وقته
المعتاد كان من المرجح ان تظهر مستويات
اعلى من اليقظه في صباح اليوم التالي ايضا
النشاط البدني في المستويات المرتفعه من
هذا النشاط خلال اكثر من 10 ساعات عن
اليوم السابق تزيد من مستويات اليقظه في
الصباح ايضا تاثير وجبه الفطور على اليقظه
في الصباح فقد ارتبط استهلاكه هذه الوجبه
عاليه الكربوهيدرات بمستويات اعلى من
اليقظه الصباحيه في المقابل تم ربطه وجبه
الفطور عاليه البروتين بمستويات يقظه اقل
كما اكتشف الباحثون ان الحاله المزاجيا
الايجابيه وكبروا السن وانخفاض معدل تناول
الطعام النهار يؤثر بشكل عام على مستويات
اليقظه اليوميه للفرد فيما توصل الباحثون
الى ان العوامل الوراثيه كان لها تاثير
ضئيل على مستويات اليقظه لدى الفرد ما
يشير الى تاثير اكثر باهميه لعوامل نمط
الحياه التي يمكن تعديلها